how's it going everybody it's Warren
and a couple of nights ago Marvel sent
out a tweet that sent everybody on the
internet into a frenzy I did a quick
video on this yesterday but since then
we have learned more new information
about what exactly is going on so like I
said a couple of nights ago Marvel
tweeted a very cryptic tweet the tweet
had Roman numerals 2 4 5 6 & 9 and also
in the tweet was a picture of a bunch of
code and a link to marvel's website with
the title test slash do not publish
confidential and when you click on the
link that is the first thing that pops
up as a supposed title test slash do not
publish
- confidential then it has some code
right below it and then where the author
would normally be of an article it says
published by test moderator - and then
when you scroll down you can find three
files that have a bunch of redacted
information and each being titled
research memorandum the three files read
weapon one which is believed to be
Captain America weapon X which is
believed to be Wolverine and weapon 13
which is believed to be phantom X so
I'll break down what this cryptic tweet
means and what all of this code means in
this video but first a quick reminder
about my giveaway at the 450,000
subscriber mark I'll be picking three
winners and each will get to choose a
one item from the Marvel Legends series
collection you must be subscribed to my
channel to enter and I'll talk more
about the giveaway at the end of the
video so like I said this sent the
internet into a frenzy last night and I
got a ton of tweets a ton of DMS asking
me if this is the x-men coming into the
MCU and nothing is confirmed at all but
I'll talk about what I think this does
mean so for starters Marvel published
this exactly the way it is it is meant
to look like it's some type of leak it's
meant to look like there's confidential
information that was spilled online that
was not supposed to be but this is just
Marvel making it look like that so no
Marvel didn't accidentally post
something that wasn't supposed to be
posted this is exactly how it's supposed
to look the next thing is like I said
there are three different files on here
with redacted information and even
though
information is redacted we can pretty
much figure out who these people are the
first one says research memorandum
weapon one and based off of all the
information that you can still see in
this report we can tell that it is
indeed Captain America the date of birth
is 1918 the residents as Brooklyn New
York and the service is the US Army then
down below we can see that it says US
Army rejected because Captain America
was initially rejected and as you
continue to read you can see things like
super soldier enhanced to its peak
potential symbol of hope Avengers lead
shield and the Winter Soldier so as you
can see here it's pretty obvious that
this is Captain America and they are
saying that he is weapon one so probably
their first experiment
the next is Weapon X which we can
clearly tell is Wolverine and this one
is very obvious it says things like
mutation program experimenting atom
meant 'i'm bones and claws of adamantium
the healing factor Professor Charles
Xavier and then it literally says the
x-men so there is clearly no denying
that this is Wolverine that this report
is talking about and the next report for
Weapon 13 literally says Charlie cluster
7 which we know is the alter ego of
phantom X
phantom X first appeared in new x-men in
2002 so we have Captain America
Wolverine and phantom X and they are
each labeled as weapons and our most
likely experiments now I'm sorry to
disappoint many people but if you look
at the very top of this post it says
that it's under comics so even though
everybody is already beginning to talk
about this being related to the x-men
entering the MCU it has been confirmed
that this is in fact an announcement of
a new comic series last night of day
after the tweet was sent Marvel
officially announced a Wolverine and
Captain America weapon Plus number one
comic that is coming out July 10th now
this doesn't necessarily mean that it's
not related to the x-men entering the
MCU this could be a precursor comic to
get us ready for the x-men entry
especially since Avengers in game
because they introduced alternate
timelines so now there are many
different ways to introduce them this
could also be a story that could be
canon to the MCU that is actually taking
place in an alternate timeline the one
where Captain America went back to it's
unclear right now however if you look at
the
report for each of the characters on the
top right of each report it says all
information contained herein is
unclassified and then it has a date of 6
1719 so June 17th 2019 and it says this
date on each of the reports so this is
actually going to be revealed to us on
Monday so again everybody is starting to
widely speculate on what this could mean
is this just another comic series is it
MC related or is it possibly a prelude
comic that could eventually lead to the
x-men being in the MCU unfortunately
nothing can be confirmed right now but
we'll know soon enough
on Monday the Disney Fox deal is
something that had been in the works for
a very long time Disney could have very
well anticipated the x-men returning
back home to Disney so have they been
preparing this whole entire time a way
to introduce them into the MCU and could
that way possibly begin with a prelude
comic we'll find out in just a few days
but in the meantime let me know what you
all think about this do you think this
could be a prelude comic to the x-men
entering the MCU or do you think this is
just a new series that Marvel is
releasing let me know your thoughts in
the comments down below and another
reminder about my giveaway when I hit
450,000 subscribers I'll be picking 3
winners and each will get to choose one
item from the Marvel Legends series
collection all you have to do to enter
is be subscribed to my channel like this
video and comment down below with your
thoughts and your favorite superhero or
villain as always thank you all so much
for watching
woof woof
congratulations to your desperation to
save the universe you killed half of its
population yeah you did it very nice and
dull it took you said it cost you
everything while crying like a baby now
your